in four days time our daughter's gonna
marry a guy she just met ooh Bali
millions of miles from home I just
really want to kiss you
look like I looked up for the first time
and realized everything I ever wanted
was right in front of me
I was throwing a career away just like
her mother did so I'm the only one who
can stop her she doesn't listen to him
champagne I feel like
you're gonna be my friend and you guys
have this epic friendship you've been in
so many movies together I wanted to know
when was the moment you knew that you
were going to be friends for life when
we met a week ago I
yeah when we met
why would I'm serious you make the joke
and then you're serious when I make the
joke well that's we got to change all of
that because we have to be better we
have to be better people giving
interviews yes okay so let's give an
honest answer oh it's last week
when we met yeah well
there was just an ease and a comfort and
we just
I don't know it's we're both from the
south there was a lot of booze there too
you just drip you know
after you've you know after you've
thrown up on each other you have to be
friends
isn't that kind of how it works once
you've all right and then you're like
all right I'll be your friend okay one
lesson speaking of throwing up here's
here's my favorite thing George did in
the whole movie you didn't ask me what
it was but I'm going to tell you you
know what I'm gonna say no when we were
doing the dancing scene and at one point
I'm having to chug a glass of liquor and
I'm
supposed to be so drunk that like I can
hardly choke it down and he's holding my
hair back he just grabbed my hair and
he's holding it back while I'm trying to
drink this thing and it was my favorite
thing it was just so I thought that's a
real that's a real friend it's so funny
because when I saw that I was like I
wonder if that's ever happened to them
in real life like not on never never
he's never held my hair back but never
I've never been drunk really I mean
um Julia your character Georgia has
David saved on her phone is something
really funny in the movie and it made me
wonder what you have George saved in
your phone under well schmuck
Batman
lowercase letters
wow that hurts
you should see yeah
I know you're cooking up something
really mean
I can feel it I can feel it
no I'm not going to say it I'll be nice
I have it under Jay cell no just back
hair and then
lowercase lowercase the lowercase is the
worst I
know because George with Keaton
returning I'm a major fan would you ever
would you ever give it another go well I
think that I did so well uh in the first
one that I think I don't think I can top
the work that I did with uh you know
lines like freeze freeze you know oh
because it's two two freezes I was cold
just you doing that I wasn't ready no we
tried it because it's two words but it's
the same word freeze freeze and I have
with different meanings yeah two
different means so I go freeze freeze
I am freezing right now yeah yeah you're
like Arnold Schwarzenegger in the movie
right now yeah that's my favorite Batman
movie by the way and I think you are the
best well then you actually have an
issue no I'm just a 90s kid I'm just a
90s kid
um you guys have also done so many cool
genres together Heist Thriller rom-com
is there a genre you would want to
tackle together that you haven't done
yet Musical yeah Opera
or a nature documentary yes that's a
that's a genre
I'll hover in the Land Rover while my
partner Jim wrestles The live alligator
um yes let's do a a a a musical animal
thing let's do a a African musical sure
Opera sure yeah good or like an Italian
David Attenborough Out of Africa Arya
yes that'll play well out of Arya out of
Arya you're so proud of Arya mines
I'm out of Arya time
we had to join our club I love it I can
do this all day you guys are absolutely
fantastic your chemistry's so effortless
I wish I could put it in a bottle and
take it with me on dates you can
actually selling it we'll be selling it
at the concession of the movie we'll be
there in the back yeah this is good day
good day
hey you've learned that to make me look
bad you don't need my help there uh you
guys are so funny in this movie oh I at
first just had to ask you about the beer
pong scene yeah because it was so good
tell me about shooting that like who had
the best shot and what was it like
playing that game with George and Julia
well first of all George is really good
at it I never missed a shot so that was
never yeah for like the the you know
really like you've been practicing oh my
God
I also have never I actually just for
the first time after the movie but at
the time when we shot it I have never
played beer pong before in my life oh
wow and then when I actually just
recently did it I think maybe I was
taking some pointers from George and I
it was actually really good and they
were kind of like shocked because I was
like I've never played before but then I
actually did really well
um but no and also everybody thinks that
like we were actually drinking during
that scene which is not the case at all
um especially George and Julia they
really seemed like they were intoxicated
and they were not it was all just watch
water we just saw that first take first
scene and we're just like oh my God this
is brilliant this is yeah yeah we were
in awe of what they were doing because
we weren't expecting it that that whole
bit was supposed to be choreographed or
I think that was originally the plan but
they were like no we've got this and
we're like oh what does that mean and
then and then they did that in the
movies like basically all one take they
just had like two cameras and they just
went for it and were catching all of
those moments and it was genius it
really was it came off so far people
loved it I think when we yeah when we
when we premiered in London people
clapped
oh my God yeah when I was watching it
last night like everyone was just
laughing so hard it just took you back
that's why I wanted to first ask you
guys about that but obvious like was it
just a dream to work with them and what
I guess what advice would you have to um
a young actor going into a movie with
George and Julia oh interesting that's a
good question you you know I feel like
I've always been you know I've worked
with a lot of can I asked you this
question when I get it yeah
I mean I think there's really no set
formula obviously but I think that when
you're I mean I've haven't such I've had
such an amazing opportunity to work with
such brilliant actors that I look up to
so much and it's really nerve-wracking
when you feel like you're the like
you're the kid on set and you don't want
to bother them at all but I think just
like my advice would be just to not be
afraid of that and to just like go for
it because it will affect the
performance and the outcome of of the
movie and the scene so
um and it really helps when they are
just so welcoming and nice and sweet and
Julia immediately felt like uh she has
such a motherly and comforting energy
that was instant and she made me feel so
at ease I really look up to her in so
many ways and George again is like such
a good time to be around I mean
literally everybody loves someone said
he's helping move cables and lift things
and constantly just like active always
like the man doesn't sit down yeah he
doesn't when are you tired
I'm always on it's so funny I love um
what you just said about Julia because
there's a moment towards the end of the
film where Caitlyn you have a scene with
Julia and it's just you too and it's a
little emotional and I remember watching
it and I was thinking I wonder what
Caitlyn's thinking right now and and is
she observing or learning anything from
her in this moment and so I wanted to
ask you about that scene she is so
um especially with the words that she
says to to Lily are so like profound and
the way that she says it I just felt
like like there was like I couldn't do
anything else but believe exactly what
she was saying and she's so good at what
she does and she really just lets the
dialogue be what it is and she's so
natural and grounding in every way
possible
um that scene was really cool just
because I don't know one-on-one with
Julia in a movie
in that kind of scene where it's you
know
two characters basically apologizing to
each other and there's so much love
there and
I love her so much and it just felt like
it was the really just the best day
making that scene come to life oh I love
hearing that Maxim I wanted to ask you
the same about George because you have
so many great solo scenes of them and
then do you carry him at one point in
the film do I remember that I was like
do I remember this correctly so I need
to hear about that so we were we were
planning
I'll pick him up any day so we were we
were supposed to pick up all together
but it was so complicated I don't know
how we're gonna do that like out of the
water and stuff and we had the camera
fooling us so I said George how about if
we just uh like uh how about if I just
pick you up ah good idea
I was just like okay five hours later I
was still picking you up
it was it was awesome did you learn
anything from your time with him like by
just observing him and the scenes you
guys had together I mean I I've observed
a lot I guess and I've seen his movie uh
even before so you know no like finding
out that he was actually the the person
that like I've always known you know
like through whatever interview
something was just like oh my God person
you know he's really got a full-on he
loves his job it was funny my producer
um was telling me that you both were in
a movie called One Fine Day a separate
movie so I just thought that was like
yeah it was an extremely bad guy though
so funny yeah yeah well it's nice to see
you like in this rom-com and in this
space both of you guys were so good and
the relationship was so fun
um Caitlyn you were mentioning earlier
about working with these like huge
actors and obviously you know you worked
with Keaton and dope sick and now
Clooney and took it to paradise and I'm
just such a big Batman fan you've worked
with two Batman so I need to know do you
feel the bat signal calling you would
you ever want to be in a bathroom no I'm
not even having shoes between a Batman
which I cannot do no I am not cruel
George asked me and I'm like George no I
can't I love you both so much I really
can't wait George Clooney asked you he's
like he asked me every day I'm like I'm
not not doing it not doing this with you
so I'm not gonna do it
um it's hilarious but uh yes I would
love are you talking like the Batman
world they're just like yes I would
that's like
a thing that I haven't done yet and
really wanting to do I've always wanted
to be in like a superhero type role like
kind of dream job love it yeah I'd love
to be a Batman yeah yeah
of course you know I mean it's always
been
uh it's always been a dream of mine you
know since I was a kid I mean I've
always watched superhero movies you know
of course one day I would love to pop
supports everything I do that's because
everything she does is perfect he's
exaggerating are you I'm really not
Lucas I am so excited for you because I
know you've been working for like 10
years now yes and the fact that your
face is on a big screen twice in the
last three months I mean like that just
must be so insane for you
it it is yes I'm I'm uh I'm just I'm
just very humbled by the the responses
that I get and
to be lucky enough to you know uh
be in such inspiring stories and Men
provide entertainment and escapism it's
it's uh
it's it's hard to it's hard to measure
yeah I'm just I'm just trying to stay
focused on the fact that it's supposed
to be fun and I I want to be able to
capture all the essence of it yeah well
you did and it's funny I hope you had
fun doing it because it's so much fun
watching you in this your paw is so
clumsy and I was reading that you said
that the physicality was a little it was
a little bit of an uncomfortable
challenge for you and I was wondering
he's so amazingly clumsy and hilarious
what did you look to did you look to
anything to sort of find that or did you
watch anything that inspired you I work
with the I work with colors and animals
um wow so basically I found it when
you're looking for a physicality it's
always interesting
to find what animal this character would
be in life you know
and uh
so for this one I I I I went with a I
went with a slot
which I paired with a hamster
and it's I know it's very weird I don't
even know why I'm sharing this process
but what do you mean this is amazing
sometimes if you're gonna play a black
predatorial bad guy you know you're
gonna go baby for a wolf and You observe
the physicality and you it kind of gives
you something and for this one it was
very like it's it's all about love and
so confident and happy that for me the
slot with this you know Applause and
always wanted to hug you and hug a tree
so that this was for the love and and
the hamster was like this kind of thick
you know on the wheel like spinning off
the wheel like bumping into a thing so I
kind of made that soup and um and and it
was Spotlight it just it just came
exactly the way I so funny you say that
because now it's like I literally
pictured all those movements did you
watch videos of because I've seen sloths
in Costa Rica amazing literally to not
exert energy like move that slowly
yeah I watched a lot of videos I mean I
didn't spend I wasn't portraying a
hamster or a sloth so I didn't go that
deep but
um it's giving sloth
you know that moment where it's like
surprise and he's like oh you know all
that little hand gesture that it's all
like upstairs I also wanted to ask you
you about the kiss you have with Julia
because it's so it's it's like iconic
cringe and so amazing cut it cringe what
was it like shooting that that's that's
a cool uh Association iconic cringe
that should be that this should be my
biography name iconic cringe by Lucas
Bravo I would read it yes yeah it's a
two-page biography
one page is about slots
two pages signed by George Clooney
and you have to take a casamigo shop
before what was it like shooting that
scene
um
wait which you know we're talking about
the kids oh yes
um
well it's it's just a kiss you know at
the end of the day it's yeah you have to
forget about the fact that you know
every single movie Julia's been in that
you're a fan that she's the most
beautiful woman in the world the most
talented and when she smiles butterflies
are flying and Rainbows are shooting in
the sky so you put all your life
yourself aside and you become Paul so I
was with my sloth and my hamster and I
was like okay kissing sin I love this
person so much I wanna
uh yeah it's you know we're
professionals at the end of the day we
cannot we cannot be distracted by our
uh fanaticism yeah like being a fan of
someone yeah absolutely what about with
George because well with George wickest
we we kissed with we I was a fan and
everybody was just yeah I I couldn't
hold it you couldn't hold it then two
twice six years men alive like I
couldn't I had to yeah I know two times
sexy it's wild I was reading that Julia
Roberts really wanted someone cast as
Paul that would really piss off George
Clooney you saw your tape she was like
there he is that is so funny so what was
it like being able to play a character
that gets under George Clooney's skin
and did you have any fun moments with
him on set
it's it's it's I get that a lot but at
the same time we we at such a beautiful
relationship with Georgia it's hard to
imagine that that could ever get under
his skin
uh because it just took me under his
wing and helped helped me navigate this
entire Journey gave me such great advice
and just made me made this entire
experience uh a dream you know we
laughed we played we we
drank we everything was just uh
everything was a good memory it's always
good news you know did you ask him about
that we talked about it we talked about
it and I was like you know George you
need you need to be
don't be so hard on your Batman he I
actually loved it as a kid I loved it he
didn't believe me and I was like I'm a
90s kid yeah me too yeah I was
I love the eyes and the surfing on the
dinosaur and he he wouldn't believe that
I was actually not being sarcastic it's
a reference in my childhood and and
um
so yeah
um one day one day you'll believe me I'm
still working on that
um well I'm so excited for people to see
in this
you are also going to be in another
rom-com called the honeymoon and I was
thinking about how the honeymoons in
Italy and ticket to Paradise is in Bali
and Miss Harris goes to Paris and Emily
in Paris is in Paris and so I was
wondering for your next project where do
you hope
that that project or that film or plot
takes place I would love to shoot
something in Japan
be amazing they would be like oof I
could end my career like okay thank you
good I I just the idea of being you know
in a location for the the for three
months like it's it's perfect because
you really have time to you know dive in
and know the place and uh I would love
to shoot a movie in Japan is there a
genre that you that you love to explore
that's not like in the romantic comedy
I love everything as long as the story
as a meaning I think it I love
um uh and from kind of informational
movies uh you know like Mark Ruffalo
does you know Spotlight dark Waters
movies
based on a true story and that you know
gives a message that everybody should
hear and um
I don't know add a little gravitas to my
to my uh range
I love that well I can't wait to see you
in a future informational film what
advice again I can't leave without audio
about what advice do you have
um for someone trying to get along with
their exes with their partner's EX
um I don't know I'm I'm in good term
With All My Exes so I'm not a great
advice for that I think you should
always uh you should always leave a
story
before
um before the sourness kicks in you know
when you're still friends and there's
still love and it's hard to to do
because as a normal human being you want
to
um Salvage that love you want to save it
from burning but there's a moment where
you have to sacrifice that the last bits
of love that you have and leave if you
want to stay friends for a long time
which I always uh which I'm able to do
for some reason
so just just leave when it's still still
time there you go it's not for the faint
of heart this is not his first rodeo
okay let's go let's go here we go which
one there's only one I see two oh yeah
[Music]
oh no no Dad please stop doing that
oh my God
I'm praying for an asteroid oh as a
hopeful romantic I just want to thank
you for bringing this romantic comedy a
hopeful romantic screen hopeful romantic
yes you never heard that time how's that
how's that going for you absolutely
fabulous fantastic yeah we're still
waiting on my meet cute okay but um I
love rom-com so much obviously as do
many people and I wanted to know why do
you why do you think people love them
and why do you think we need them I
think we need them now because these are
dark and desperate times I think and so
anything that brings also I think
consciously with it we did have the
chance for this movie to sell it to
streamers and to you know they have to
go straight to smaller rooms and smaller
screens and and it was very important to
us to make a movie to laugh to try and
get a lot of people in a room laughing
together do you know what I mean because
that's something we've all missed
desperately over the last three years so
um yeah I think it's incredibly needed
these are difficult times and so
anything that can provide I started
writing it with my friend Dan at the
beginning of the pandemic and just the
writing of it was an antidote to the
smallness and difficulty and darkness
and fear that we were all living through
and so just to be writing something in
Sunny climbs with funny people was
amazing so then to get to make it was
ridiculous it's so surreal how are you
feeling now having just explained that
and here we are and it's not out yet the
world hasn't seen it so how are you
feeling like right now I feel I mean
it's been lovely so far it's been really
nice we had to Premiere in London a
couple of weeks ago and that was great
and so yeah proud and you know anxious
obviously but um you know but yeah I
mean thrilled I'm grateful yeah but I
mean you're such a veteran you know you
have done like the Mamma Mia movie you
know here we go again Mamma Mia The Best
Exotic Marigold Hotel what would you say
are like the key ingredients to a
successful rom-com in this modern era
because seeing George and Julia I'm I
was born in the 90s yeah so it there is
some Nostalgia there yeah but for the
modern era what are those key successful
you got a cat I think you gotta care you
could in the end you can be funny you
know it's yeah not to forget the wrong
basically in the calm like you've got to
care and I think maybe where the genre
started to fail is that you stopped
caring and it started to be more about
set pieces and alerts from set pieces at
peace and the cliches became a bit more
obvious the airport dash of the public
declaration so let's be kind of overused
you know what I mean or you feel like
you've seen them and you stopped caring
and so the great thing about working
with these guys apart from the fact that
they're Geniuses and gorgeous and all
that stuff is the kind of shared history
that they bring with them and just how
much people want to believe in their
friendship and want to see them hook up
do you know I mean maybe not literally
but you know we've had the screening the
other night and they there's a kiss in
the movie and there was just Applause in
the cinema which I've rarely heard
because that's how much people want them
to be together so in the end that you
have to care that's would be my main
ingredient yeah it's so true because I
also read that you said you know you
could have the best script ever in the
most amazing backdrop but sometimes it
lands on the chemistry of the two leads
did I say that yeah I read that you said
that thank you very much no yeah not
that I'm arguing that this is either of
those things but um yeah you've gotta
that's that's the bird in the end it's
like all the fuss behind the camera
doesn't matter what's on screen and
you've got to wonder in the end you need
to want to see the two of them hook up
you know in whatever form yeah yeah
that's what you need and so if you have
that and George and Julia bring that
with them which is a gift for me it
makes much better than it's and you're
giving that gift you're sharing
everything thank you because I I was
also reading that you read this I'm
sorry you wrote this script with both of
them as the leads yeah in the very first
conversation so I was wondering was
there film that they did together and
was there like a scene that they had
together previously that was in um
Brilliance the Ted Griffin or Oceans 11
and talk I think but it's a brilliant
scene where she's like she says you're
allowing a thief and he says I never
lied about being a thief which is I
think probably the best two lines I've
ever written
um and then he says does he make you
laugh about Andy Garcia and she goes he
doesn't make me cry which is also a
brilliant bit of writing so um but it's
also just their shared friendship on and
off screen and off screen as well do you
know the the history of them do you know
what I mean but so the way they play
together uh you know it's just it was
just brilliant for me and they really do
their friendship's real and genuine and
will last forever so it's a beautiful
thing yeah and I actually you went
downstairs and I actually went into the
room to talk to them right after you and
you could just feel their friendship I
was telling them that I wish that I
could bottle up their chemistry and take
it with me on dates and they were joking
and they were like yeah you could buy it
in the gift shop after it would be nice
I'd buy some I
and then I go okay we're just going to
relay it will be 20 minutes and normally
actors will go back to their trailers
and do the thing and they would just
stay there and we would like around them
and they'd be laughing together in the
middle and then you'd be like okay ready
and they go okay cool and then they
carry on it so it's just it's warm and
it's real and their families love each
other and uh Danny Julius husband was
there and uh I'm always there with the
kids and so and Juliet you know popped
around you know she's like a godmother
to both the kids and you know it's
lovely I mean nothing but a gift for me
and to hang out with them is a you know
pure joy what's been so fun did you
learn anything from having done you know
other sort of rom-coms by watching
George Clooney and Julia Roberts yeah I
mean she's the she's the queen she's the
queen and when she says she has she's
very they're both very good at taking
stuff away I don't need that I don't
need that I can do that with the look
you know they're amazingly good at
knowing what's right and what and tell
me what's right so um yeah every day it
was a school day for me yeah are one
thing in particular that you could share
with us that you were like wow that's
interesting I've never picked up on that
yeah actually I mean the thing the
younger actors took from there is their
work ethic it's how hard they work
there's them radio mined and so I have
cancer and there's one day we did it's
really hot day and by the end of the day
both Billy and Caitlin would admit that
they were slightly flagging and I could
hear George and Julia going and we still
got it and we still got it because every
tank they're just bang on they know
everyone else's loans they know where
the camera is you know they're just and
it's not just experience it's
commitments as well and they'd have fun
and they do have fun they love what they
do but they work really hard and that's
obviously another gift for me it's so
good
um you mentioned the younger actors
Caitlyn is just she's so incredible did
you see her in anything previously
something else that didn't work out and
so she was my friend and then I bumped
into her a bit before it and said I've
written something for you I'm going to
send it to you and normally that's a
really Naf chat outline you know what I
mean which is incredibly not what it was
and she's like yeah sure great and I
already have so um yeah it was the
easiest city in the world and then
George and Julia were both huge fans of
her so I think I told them not I didn't
ask their permission but I said I'm
gonna offer Lily to Caitlyn Diva and
they're both oh amazing so um yeah it
was a really happy thing so all three of
them were sort of in my head all the way
through the writing yeah it's amazing it
never works out no it was it was so good
and she actually like looks like that
you know she's yeah I had photos
on the wall and I was like yeah I could
see
he like was so hilarious yeah because
he's so he's obviously the most handsome
man in the world and that's fine and so
his tape came in and I was like oh great
he's the handsome it's the hot Chef
remember in Paris and I didn't I have to
sit down to it with enormous excitement
and within about 10 seconds just like oh
okay and then I called him up and we
worked on it together and he's just his
love if you talk to him he said love me
guys you'll fall in love he's a lovely
guy you're hopeful romantic meet Luca's
brother yeah meet Luca's brother so um
no he's Sensational and um yeah it was
brilliant telling Julia it was him as
well